hey what's going on a spill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday October 14th 2019 what's going on
and how are you how's it going can you
wash your feet I could wash my feet this
is how we take a bath
sorry I got to sing it out of my head or
just be my [ __ ] head for the whole
damn day all these goddamn Kidsongs
you know you think they're silly and and
you know they're educational
they're thinking about the children but
you just think that all this is I could
literally write this so there's a genius
to what they do
it just gets whatever the [ __ ] they want
to teach a kid they get it in that
sing-songy thing because as an adult it
gets in my head and I can't I can't
[ __ ] can you wash your face I can
wash my face this is how you take a bath
all [ __ ] you know there's the clean
clean up everybody clean up clean up
everybody clean up clean up clean up put
your [ __ ] away
I don't want the real word distant they
use I literally be like doing the dishes
that I'm cleaning and I was just clean
please slowly going nuts and I think
that the people in power design that kid
music to teach your kids what they want
you to learn and at the same time it's
it begins the dyeing process in the
adult that listens to it you know what I
mean it's like that Sam Rockwell movie
moon oh I don't know ruin it for you but
you know whatever out with the old in
with the new I'll leave it at that
I'll leave it with that I will leave it
hey no good deed goes unpunished that's
what I learned this [ __ ] week you
know you try to be a nice guy you try
all bill you the victim in this you all
yes I am you know I guess my problem is
that
I care too much oh man I had why is the
podcast so late bill we need
explanations as to why this free thing
took so long to get to our ears okay you
know something I just realized today do
you know do you know what uber and lyft
are it's it's millennial thumbing that's
basically what you're doing well
hitchhiking you just go out and stick
your thumb out and hope that the person
who [ __ ] went to pick you up wasn't a
goddamn serial killer
that's essentially what you're doing
with uber and lyft with their [ __ ]
background checks they have such little
background checks you'll see a car that
will we'll have uber and lyft stickers
on this guy's LEDs on both sides huh or
is that Ave is that because that's Ave
is it a hermaphrodite uber lyft driver I
don't know I don't know how it works
these days that's basically what you're
doing you're thumbing I guess the cars
smell nicer if you get a nice enough one
but I swear to god they're out there
just causing [ __ ] traffic they're
just out there driving around you
already have taxis and now you have like
movies call them gypsy cabs or thumbing
that's what we used to call it is that
what used to call it bill did you also
used to do the [ __ ] Macarena huh
drink drinking a Zima what else did you
used to do bill nobody cares about you
and the 80s and the 90s oh come on
you're supposed to respect your elders
so this morning you know I come
downstairs my wife and kid aren't home
they want to go visit a relative and
they came now they're home but like you
know I'll tell you right now being at
home in the old [ __ ] piece-of-shit
house that I bought that I now fixed up
that is now great I'll never get my
money back so I can never leave you know
Bronx Tale that's the situation I've had
it all you name it I've had it need a
new roof check driveway check garage
check upstairs check downstairs check in
the walls out of the walls
animals alive dead water pouring through
the I i I've had it all you ever watch a
TV show where they try to do too much
there's just too much story going on you
know it's been this [ __ ] house
so anyway alright I know what the [ __ ] I
was talking about so I come downstairs
and when you live in an old house and
you're the only one in it it's at night
it's scary it's weird during the day but
at night it's definitely this just it's
just creepy because we live in an old
house even if nobody else is home and
like it sounds it sounds like there is
even if there's nobody else home with
you it sounds like there is it's what
I'm trying to say you just hear [ __ ] you
know
everybody thinks oh it's cuz it's
haunted it's that's cuz it's haunted
it's cuz it's old and nothing works and
it's [ __ ] trying to get comfortable
in the dirt
you know [ __ ] haunted Jesus Christ if
you were ghosts wouldn't you move into a
nicer [ __ ] house you live wherever
the [ __ ] you wanted to live I never
understood that you know maybe they go
out during the day that's why you don't
hear him you know just laying on the
street waiting for some woman in a skirt
to walk by so they can look up but then
why would I would be such a [ __ ]
pervert if I was a ghost
Jesus crawl but that would be such a sad
day when you saw every famous chick that
you'll [ __ ] seen in the movies
watched him take a shower as your jerk
your [ __ ] ghost of Jesus Christ bill
what are we doing if you can put your
hand through the wall as a ghost
can you still jerk it you're [ __ ] go
stick all you paranormal people can you
answer that when you come in with your
[ __ ] flashlights taped to a weed
whacker whatever the [ __ ] it is you're
doing to try and find out what your
ghost tracking this tracks paranormal
let me see that [ __ ] on those [ __ ]
Ghost Hunters show the [ __ ] that they
have I swear to God it reminds me of
Green Acres with that guy lives here
you want paranormal finder wait didn't I
used to do a bit about that I did do a
bit about that that I ever put it on I
don't know if I could put that out I
think that one may have stayed home so
anyway my I wake up you know the house
is talking to me you know it's funny
when you're making the payments on the
house you never think it's haunted you
immediately think of Oh God what what
noise is that and how much is that going
to cost me
it never enters my mind that I have to
hire a four foot eleven woman with a
helium Voice to come in and exorcise the
demons so I get up to do my podcast I
got everything all set up I'm ready to
go I go to go to my [ __ ] Gmail my
[ __ ] Gmail and like every three
months these [ __ ] Gmail [ __ ] they
just try to get information out of you
hey here's a way here's a way to make
your personal account more secure give
us more of your personal information
it's like why would I do that
you're obviously having security
problems hey can we have your phone
number
no Gmail you can't have my phone number
how many [ __ ] times do I have to say
no no means no in this post me to
[ __ ] world that we're living in you
would think that these these these these
technological [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
you call them we're just out there
sharing all this [ __ ] information I'm
telling you man all these all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] did you see that thing
there's a commercial out right now
there's a goddamn doorbell right and
these crooks are walking up to the thing
to break into the guy's house and it's
lit up and they're like oh wait you see
that circle oh [ __ ]
and then they just show the nerdiest guy
ever he's like at the gym this total
[ __ ] guy so I guess he's at the gym
trying to put us a little bit of
beefcake there either to get some ladies
or I don't know what and he's gone and
he starts talking through the speaker
going saying a bunch of [ __ ] that he
would never say to their face if he was
standing there be like hey well what
room do you want to start in first but
now he's you know he's the big tough
[ __ ]
millennial [ __ ] he's at the gym engaging
his core whatever the [ __ ] it is you
know they run down the street carrying
tables what do you call that
CrossFit you know hey if you're in
[ __ ] medical school right now is a
young person get into joint replacements
at tattoo removal you're gonna make a
fortune right around 35 to 50 so he goes
yeah if I was you I you know I earn
around and run talking all this [ __ ]
like he's [ __ ] Steve McGarrett right
all of this [ __ ] this is what I don't
get about all of that stuff is like you
get these cameras set up we were selling
that [ __ ] on the podcast and I be
reading the [ __ ] to copy oh wait a
minute
so this will film the criminal in your
house so this has the ability to film in
your house what's to prevent will be
nice about this some rogue employee from
just turning that on and then you get
the flat-screen TVs with the [ __ ]
camera
what's the they let stop mrs. mrs.
zenith from turning that [ __ ] thing
on and watching you I don't know it
becomes like a weird thing I feel like
the house in the future if you want to
run for president someday you have to
have all you do all your [ __ ] and all
your conversating and all your [ __ ]
masturbating in the hallways you know I
think you can get like a cheap like
video surveillance thing for in your
house and just say like yeah listen I
don't you know all the valuables and all
the people are gonna be in rooms so you
don't need to show the hallways you got
to have a you got to have like basically
what was the panic room you gotta have
your panic room where you can actually
you know in the future you can go you
could be in your house and say whatever
sexist whatever [ __ ] crazy thing you
want to say you can jerk off
you can [ __ ] you know talk about your
mother-in-law your father-in-law your
[ __ ] cousin whatever
whatever family member you want to
[ __ ] talk about you just have like
this dis you know
this dark spot well you're not picked up
and you know and I think it should be
the laundry room then what you do is in
the future you just turn on the washing
machine and the dryer at the same time
so there's a lot of [ __ ] background
noise you grab a pillow and then you
yell all this [ __ ] that you want to do
right and you put a pillow over
somebody's face that you want to bang so
their moans don't you know make all the
companies curious that they're missing
out on the good stuff that they want to
watch when you're was this too paranoid
I don't know it's funny because they
used to always say that like Big Brother
was always going to be watching you and
it just turns out to be a bunch of them
a bunch of [ __ ] perverts like what's
this I don't know pictures done the
whole thing freaks me out so anyway so I
[ __ ] go I go to get on Gmail yeah
they're asking me all of this [ __ ] and
there's no way I can I can't find the
microscopic little thing that says opt
out I can't [ __ ] find it and then I
go to turn on my recorder and then the
batteries will report or whatever I need
to be charged to some [ __ ] so I that's
why it's [ __ ] late alright but I got
to tell you something you know by what I
say just [ __ ] [ __ ] over this [ __ ] we
have enough technology this [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] well you just can be
walking around and all at all times just
be filming people I don't get it where
it's just like what what has happened to
you in life that you need like
presidential level security and then
everybody else's privacy is now
compromised you know just the whole
[ __ ] thing with like the emails and
[ __ ] why am i conversing on this [ __ ]
why is like the most important business
should I have basically out there where
anybody can get it the whole thing is
stupid this reminds me of the [ __ ]
banks you know yeah go to the banks
these [ __ ] [ __ ] hey you don't have
money in your log cabin oh [ __ ] FEMA
gonna come down and take
bring you work all week and then you
bring our money to us we'll keep it nice
and safe the biggest [ __ ] scam ever
one giant [ __ ] Ponzi scheme [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but let's get let's get to bread and
circus now that I'm about twelve
thirteen minutes into the podcast here
thirteen and a half there right
oh what a week for the Patriots is there
anything better than when your team
plays on Sunday wins and then plays on
Thursday and wins you get two wins it
one [ __ ] in four day period and then
you know they're gonna rest up you know
you got your cake and eat it as a fan
and then Sunday you can just sit down
it's sort of weird it's like your team
got kicked out of the league like
[ __ ] SMU back in the day when it got
put on probation which is great to see
them hovering around the top twenty
again I hope they make a nice comeback
[ __ ] the women on that thing ruined
that they had them build a [ __ ]
Stadium half the size because they
didn't want to deal with all that
boosters [ __ ] it's like this is Texas
it's all about football and [ __ ]
buying people gold Trans Am [ __ ] are you
talking about anyway I don't talk about
this goddamn football [ __ ] the Kansas
City Chiefs lose again but they're
talking about my home's ankle I don't
know but meanwhile out in the NFC West
I'll tell you two teams that are looking
pretty scary to me is San Francisco
49ers in the Seattle Seahawks with old
sneaky pete up they're all out the back
door Carol right there gradually coming
back but you know what's great about
being the Seattle Seahawks is their way
to [ __ ] up there and nobody pays
attention to him games are always coming
on late you know the fan base is just a
bunch of Lumberjacks and [ __ ] earthy
crunchy fat chicks and just it just it's
not sexy it's not a sexy fan base they
had a little blip there where they had a
little music scene going on in the early
90s and then you know that was quickly
you know absorbed by all corporations
the next thing you know you bought
flannel shirts at a [ __ ] Jake roof
right
what are they comes distressed or
stressed makes it looks like you've been
wearing them long before the fad came
out so nobody pays attention to them you
know as my good friend Paul virzi has
already [ __ ] at numerous times crown
the Patriots Super Bowl champions this
year much like during most of this run
the the AFC just always seems to be weak
certainly the [ __ ] AFC's who the [ __ ]
to the Jets beat this they beat the
Cowboys Jesus Christ how [ __ ] pissed
is their fan base huh flipping the [ __ ]
out I guess they got new some new
offensive coordinator or some [ __ ]
defensive coordinator and he was making
the calls and they were winning three
and then they try to say that Garrett
guy [ __ ] took over that was the
suspicion and that's why they lost the
next three and then they're saying Tony
Romo said this has got Garrett's
fingerprints all over it and all the
conspiracy football players just started
[ __ ] putting [ __ ] together right I
love a good sports conspiracy I got one
for you the end of the game there's an
unwritten [ __ ] rule that at the end
of the [ __ ] game if it's close enough
the referees are gonna do everything in
their power to give the team with the
ball that's down a chance to come down
and tie the game so what they can do is
ensure that they have the most exciting
product as they would call it that they
can [ __ ] put out there because I got
to tell you something right now
that [ __ ] into that Cowboys game and
I know the Cowboys got absolutely
[ __ ] screwed on that [ __ ]
offensive pass interference call almost
like the ref didn't understand the the
rule and I got to tell you after it was
explained to me and then I acted like I
knew it all along I was really upset
with that referee it was just every pass
that was [ __ ] incomplete it was past
interference then on one pass in a fair
day they basically they also hit the
quarterback pretty hard they were just
like oh yeah better penalty I'd say I
don't [ __ ] get it you can call pass
interference on every [ __ ] play but
you get old and they
but you could also call holding on every
play on the offensive line which they
never do so how do [ __ ] does that work
and I'm not saying that the Jets didn't
interfere a couple of times but
everything to call every [ __ ] one of
those when the game was on light and
this is what's hilarious
before that drive even started they were
down by eight points I was like oh
they're gonna score they're gonna go
right down the field and they're gonna
[ __ ] score and it's gonna come down
to the two-point conversion you just
knew what was gonna alright now I know a
lot of this [ __ ] I don't know think they
talking about now they're trying to
protect players more and if they really
gave a [ __ ] about the players they would
they would have given them the former
players some sort of decent settlement
which they didn't came out to like 1200
bucks a piece and as all these owners
sit there in these days these [ __ ]
you know billionaires with no [ __ ]
brain trauma if they actually gave a
[ __ ] about the players so I think it's
it's you know thirty thirty percent man
I mean that maybe twenty percent up for
the players well-being and then the
other 20 percent is like you know so
it's still you know a game that parents
will let their kids play and then the
last 60 percent it's just all about
money and ratings because I was just
watch it was like who's that it was
[ __ ] ridiculous
and they just let the Cowboys just march
right down the field and then they
called pass interference so much they
then had a make up call on the Cowboys
on some horseshit I don't know the whole
thing just seemed like this looks
ridiculously manipulated we got off set
and files on the plate we got one team
trying to stop the other team the other
team trying to score
there's too much time left we got to
just sort of hear talk for a minute with
southern accents before we get it going
again so we can ensure more commercials
before the inevitable attempt at the
two-point conversion I don't know Kevin
Hart um but I do have an old car and
yeah I definitely think that this
there's some sort of [ __ ] going on
there some sort of [ __ ] is going on
towards the end of the game where you're
trying to just like ensure the most
exciting outcome okay you know it's a
[ __ ] show it for herself whatever I
hate to admit this but I feel myself
kind of pulling away from NFL football
NBA basketball I just and I was kind of
more excited about watching racing
yesterday and I swear to God I actually
watched a little bit of the Premier
League I know I know but I think this is
the normal progression of getting old
what happens is is the game changes
there's new kids coming in you just
don't it's not what it was like you can
never go home again and then you have to
and then you also realize like amen you
know I'm [ __ ] 51 19 years I'm gonna
be 70 am I really gonna spend half my
weekends a quarter of the year [ __ ]
sitting around watching this [ __ ] when I
could be going outside doing something
but I'm not I'm just gonna find another
sport maybe you know what it is it's the
[ __ ] celebrating I know I keep
harping on this I just I don't get it I
don't get doing a touchdown dance when
you got a first [ __ ] down and you're
up by three or down by seven you know
and I just it just comes off as like I
know they're playing with passion yada
yada yet it's like I don't I think they
all have an Instagram video loop in the
head and when they make a good play they
want to finish it up with the cherry on
top and do their little [ __ ] you know
moonwalk into the worm whatever the [ __ ]
it is they're going to do you know and
then then what happens is then if they
don't make a play they just hustle back
to the [ __ ] huddle it's like no no no
why don't you soak in the you didn't get
it done on that play
you know I [ __ ] it up dance where the
[ __ ] is that I just I don't I Drive me
up the [ __ ] wall
and the screaming when you [ __ ] dunk
a ball yelling get some guy with this
six-year-old kid the crowd was not
trying to do you up on any level but any
other opponent ran out ran out of the
paint before you finished Duncan on it
so they would be on Instagram for the
his little amount of time as possible I
just would have got half of those
[ __ ] Instagram when they're like so
and so dunk ton so and so it's like nice
yeah the guy wasn't even trying he's
trying to get the [ __ ] out of the way Oh
grandpa
whatever it's your time it's your time
now okay if that's what you guys want to
do if you want to [ __ ] dance
after you gain three yards I don't know
I just do a bit about I did a bit about
that when I first started like if I did
a dance after every time I got a [ __ ]
laugh onstage I started doing the
running man Oh drop the mic or just you
know why did chicken cross the road to
get the other side yelling at people and
then if I do a joke that bombs I just
quickly run well I still do that now I
quickly run to the next material but I
didn't I don't celebrate after the ones
that work Oh bill shut the [ __ ] up
you're still gonna watch I know I know I
am anyway
so for as much as Paul virzi the pride
of New Jersey has crowned the New
England Patriots Super Bowl champions I
really believe that you know we have a
ton of work to do and I don't know our
strength of schedule if we were a
college football team right now would be
working against us put it that way so
even an even we play Kansas City I look
at it like if Patrick mahomes isn't on a
percent healthy you know is he gonna get
healthy there's just too many [ __ ]
variables two weeks into October to be
like yeah he actually said it three
weeks ago
frizzy goes early whereas he goes
[ __ ] early barely [ __ ] taking the
second buddy a goddamn hot dog and he's
[ __ ] telling you who's gonna win the
game he goes the man goes early speaking
of that we went to Death Valley in
I don't even know what town it was in I
was gonna say in Clemson we were staying
in Townsville State upstate on a [ __ ]
lake house and could not have had a
better time was working in Asheville
North Carolina on Thursday and Friday
night I went up there I swear to God the
first night I was having so much fun
[ __ ] around and I was messing with I
was at fun down south because I always
just you know I know they're there
I have fun there and then I have fun in
super liberal cities where you know it's
just easy to kind of I know you know you
get down south you know what they went
to there in the guns [ __ ] moonshine
and cars and find out how they related
to their father I'm kidding
you play up that [ __ ] losing the Civil
War and all that crap and then you
[ __ ] go out to like the liberal
places like the San Francisco's and all
of that you know and then you just react
like really [ __ ] ignorant start
talking about the positive side of Trump
you know it's easy it's easy to get them
going so in a fun way
so yeah I was joking about them saying
you know the reason why stock-car
viewership is down is because of free
internet porn you know these guys used
to just be up there twisting on the
[ __ ] cars all the time you know
trying to get their El Camino to the
race of some [ __ ] and there was I like
to see Richard Petty went seven
championships he had free [ __ ] porn
his dick in his head
just was doing that so I did like an
hour and 40 the first night in an hour
and 25 the second night nothing from my
special and I'm good to go
it killed the crowds were [ __ ]
incredible great city Asheville and and
then we were just down at this [ __ ]
lake house just laughing our asses off
the entire time this guy next door to us
was cool as [ __ ] he had you know I can't
say what he had but it was legit and he
brought some over get everybody in
trouble
but it was definitely it was [ __ ] it
was so much fun and and Clemson my god
those people those people top-shelf
tailgaters we got there we have so much
fun at the lake house we kind of skipped
the tailgate we got there like an hour
before the [ __ ] game ninety minutes
before the game we should have been
stuck in bumper-to-bumper traffic there
was barely any traffic those people were
they were already there all these every
one of them seemed to have one of those
[ __ ] those makeshift tents we can
stand underneath it so you know get
destroyed by the Sun so you can throw it
out someday and it ends up in the ocean
and it adds to this [ __ ] problem
makes the Sun even hotter that's how we
do it right at some point someone's just
gonna have to take the Sun just one
generation it's just gonna have to take
the heat for what we're doing out here
but these [ __ ] people were just
amazing love the stadium the food might
have been the best concession food I've
had in a long [ __ ] time they had this
brisket hotdog to figure that one out
and that was delicious the pretzel was
good that I got a got all stadium food
they had a piss trough you know what I
mean that's always a good mental
exercise is you got like a [ __ ]
eight-year-old on one side and a [ __ ]
kid on the other side you got to take
your dick out I mean it's just like a
focus to piss you know then they had
like those you know those [ __ ]
faucets where there's no way to get your
hands clean where you hit it and you
there's just enough time to get your
hand underneath it and then you got a
and as you're washing your hand then you
got to hit it again so whatever whatever
the [ __ ] somebody's carrying over from
the [ __ ] toilet or the goddamn piss
trough is on top of that faucet -
goddamn nightmare but then it was great
and I will tell you it is the farthest
I've ever sat from a game with my old
person eyes I had no idea what done it
was I just because they had like really
small screens and we were in row double
K and it was sort of three steps per row
so he can do the math I counted it was
over a hundred steps going up there my
[ __ ] heart was racing you know but uh
the game stunk that was the only thing
was bad you know it was just basically
plan
clubs it wins the toss they kick out the
Clemson and Clemson scars right down the
field seven or nothing Florida State
comes out three it out climbs it right
down the field 14 to nothing so I can
Florida State one first down then three
and out I guess you can't beat three now
they get a first down and then stopped
on downs
Clemson right down the field 21 nothing
Emily alright come on what's the spread
of this game somebody had them for 27
points like Jesus Christ they might
cover this by the end of the first
quarter
you know first quarter ends it was
either 14 nothin a 21 nothing then it
was 21 nothing they stopped Florida
State again and then they just marched
right down the field 28 nothing it's
like oh no tomahawk chops just they have
a game as I'd [ __ ] set out ridiculous
is that people do that I was just like
and then they stopped them again and
then they marched right down the fields
to be 35 nothing at the half but
fortunately Florida State caused the
fumble
and they went in 21:28 nothing at the
half and we were having such a good time
at the lake house and we wanted to watch
the LSU game we just know this like
they're gonna put the scrubs and they're
gonna score another touchdown they're
gonna put the scrubs in and this is
gonna be it we thought this was gonna be
a game it's not Padilla game are we
gonna stay here roasting in the Sun are
we gonna get the [ __ ] out of here go
back to our lake house with a very
friendly neighbor and have a great
[ __ ] time watch LSU Florida and
Yankees Astros I mean it was a no
brainer so we went back know traffic had
a great time kind of stink [ __ ] dinner
corn on the cob the whole thing and I
sat on his porch in this beautiful part
of South Carolina you know I'm telling
you right now like all these people that
call all these states flyover States and
they here in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere it's like this there's a there's
a a genius and a peacefulness to it that
I cannot you can't even describe I not
only got a piece of it because I the
next day I'm like the daddy huh beside
the morning drive to Atlanta and get
[ __ ] complain you know I had that in the
back of my head I was just kind of
looking at this guy next door and he's
just sitting there fishing pulling out
his dinner you know out of the water
just walking in shooting the [ __ ]
laughing telling stories on these two
little [ __ ] boat docks that we had
and I watched on the porch it's my buddy
was making the steaks I was watching
through the glass window I was watching
the Florida LSU game and LSU finally has
like a [ __ ] legit quarterback after
all these years of watch him and
incredible game and we were all joking
going this is the death valley that we
should have gone to and I think we're
leaning towards going there next year
I'm not sure it's like I've been to a
game there so they don't want to my
buddies don't go cuz I've already been
it's like do it I will absolutely go to
another game there without a [ __ ]
doubt but I was actually thinking I'm
kind of running odda if anybody knows
another good college football atmosphere
these are ones I've been to Michigan
Ohio State Nebraska I can name be UBC
Harvard Yale that's when I was a kid
Yale was later the NC State North
Carolina Clemson Florida Miami Georgia
Alabama LSU Tennessee Texas the Red
River game at the Cotton Bowl Texas
Oklahoma Texas A&M USC and UCLA
so I'm thinking as far as like you got
to go there
Auburn but nobody for my crew wants to
go unless it's the iron bull game and
we're all married with kids so that's a
tough one because that's Thanksgiving
weekend I want to go to Florida State
when they're good what else
University of Central Florida office
sent out of nowhere I've seen that steam
I know it's a little one but those they
always have seem to have exciting games
[Music]
you gotta get some more Big Ten
obviously Penn State is
I've been a Notre Dame - what else what
else is it I was a cool one Oklahoma but
then I think that's kind of near
Washington Oregon I think that's it and
I think he kind of done as far as
Division one powerhouses maybe Wisconsin
I don't know I don't know I'm trying to
think cuz then I think I just got to
move on to [ __ ] college college hoop
I guess we'll be the one to try and
figure out I told you guys a long time
ago I actually went to a game in Indiana
when Bobby Knight was still there it was
the year they played the Spartans at
home was the year the Spartans when the
championship was the early 2000 man I
thought I had a temper that guy made me
feel good about myself but haven't said
that listen to that guys like speeches
that he gave to his kids I thought he
was [ __ ] great you know I don't know
I'm an old guy so I'm used to getting
yelled at by people older than me it was
just part of growing up
second I'm adults started screaming at
you in my generation just like oh this
guy cares how about those Bruins four
and one Brad Marchand on fire
scored his fourth [ __ ] goal our
number-one line is clicking I be I only
I watched a little bit of the first game
and I've seen highlights of a couple
others I got to get on it but now I'm
home so I couldn't get the NHL package
I'm going to start watching Congrats to
the mercedes-benz team in Formula one
six years in a row they've won the team
championship for the most points of I
guess a car builder I guess you'd call
it you know it's been great for Mercedes
great for Germany boring for the fans
but you know you got to get into that
kind of excellence once again once again
the [ __ ] Ferraris we had pole
position let's see botas was in third
cuz he passed Vettel from behind he
wasn't in second place and I think that
was I think was it Leclaire I don't
watch it too much [ __ ] to remember all
the [ __ ] names the [ __ ] race
starts Vettel had like a bet
I don't we call bad start or some [ __ ]
botas goes right the [ __ ] around him and
then Leclaire ends up bumping into
what's-his-face there the kid from
[ __ ] Red Bull knocks him out of the
[ __ ] race max Verstappen and it [ __ ]
his car up and I they well they were 1 &
2 Ferrari was him by like the [ __ ]
third lap it's just like I mean by the
first turn botas is in first place
Leclaire Leclerc with his [ __ ] name
is
i'm thinking hockey players at this
point his car is [ __ ] up he's got to
come in and next thing you know I don't
know I would Lewis Hamilton he's genius
with that [ __ ] it's like he senses some
shits gonna happen he backs off he lets
him slam into each other and he goes
around the guys he's just the [ __ ]
best and he once again he was in a
position to to win it all
I don't know I watched the whole goddamn
race I was happy for both us that he got
one and one one in a while and I do love
the Mercedes team I just wish you know
how great for him and one would be if
every other race Mercedes Ferrari at
least if he had that going on little
Ohio State Michigan going on although
that hasn't happened this century has it
I think they kind of forgot that I was
doing a podcast about [ __ ] 15 minutes
ago I don't mean on top of 36 minutes in
I haven't done anything [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh what the hell is what he call your
advertising alright here we go let's get
this [ __ ] out of the way let's hope that
[ __ ] those people who [ __ ] put
cameras in your house aren't advertising
this week there'd be a little awkward
all right oh ha oh no this isn't it is
it
no this isn't it ever buy something
online and then find out you could have
gotten it for less I haven't done that
how do how do you figure that out oh you
know what your friend tells you
nice sneakers what'd you pay for him you
don't you say when everybody says that I
don't know what you pay you you go first
what you pay for yours now I'm it's
worse than insert something personally
you can't stand here examples below
alright I like this it's worse than
being on an airplane
full of landing clappers goddamn that's
fine that's a good joke
landing Clara is the worst that must
piss off the pilot like would you think
I was gonna [ __ ] this up it's like
that's that's almost a sarcastic clap
you know when a guy who's been missing
field goals finally makes an extra point
or goalie finally makes us safe it's
worse than saying nice to meet you to
someone you've met before oh I do that
all the time
I hate when someone goes we've met
before and I want to be like you're not
famous say no but you know what I mean
I got have a bet more specific we've met
before you're not the president it's
worse when it's worse than when you ask
for directions
and they start using the words east and
west yeah that's pretty bad oh you just
look up at the Sun can I just take out
the compass not to mention I gotta come
up my own they came up with three good
ones
all right ever buy something online and
then find out you've gotten it for less
it's worse than Jesus Christ
somebody [ __ ] making a wanted trying
to make a left turn from the right lane
and stops in their lane with their
blinker on like they're doing the right
thing and there's someone left next to
him making a left and they [ __ ] drive
in front of him to make the left that's
what I just saw in the way over here
theirs is better mine was a little wordy
not to mention once that happens you
feel like you could be overpaying every
time you shop luckily there's honey the
free browser extension that saves you
time and money when shopping online
honey
scares Oscan to the internet for coupon
codes and other discounts then like
magic it automatically applies the one
with the biggest savings to your cart at
checkout it knows about every coupon
code sale or discount at over 220
thousand sites like Amazon Macy's j.crew
Domino's Sephora Target and more honey
is found it's 10 million users over
billion dollars in savings listen
there's really no reason not to use
honey it's free to use and installs in
your computer and just two clicks get
honey for free at join honeycomb / /
that's join oh honey
calm / / alright hymns is that a
hairline slough well he's starting to
move backward any bald spots yet let's
see
yeah I'd say yeah I asked you do you
want a bald spot to pop up on your hair
or your hairline to recede or do you
want to do something about it first I
can't imagine what it feels like to
start going bald let me finish to start
going bald and then stopping it you know
that's got to be like the the hair
version of like beating a deadly disease
you got three weeks to live and then you
[ __ ] beat it you know but see this is
the vain version of that bill did you
just compare losing your hair to
somebody dying of a fatal disease I
think this is like reversing a bola why
do guys turn to weird solutions or do
nothing well I mean I don't know because
you're [ __ ] putting that gunk on top
of your head and you feel your heart
start racing that's what happened to me
with that pro piece of [ __ ] when they
can turn to medicine and science granted
I did that was a long [ __ ] time ago
for hims calm my one-stop-shop for hair
loss skincare and sexual wellness for
men you like that you're gonna get your
hair back you're gonna get some more
broads out there they got to make sure
somebody's doing the [ __ ] mile house
mile I salute thanks to science baldness
can be optional through that these guys
fixed me this would be like bringing
somebody back from the dead like legit
like digging him up they've been dead
hymns is helping guys to be the best
version of themselves with licensed
physicians and fda-approved products to
help treat hair loss prescription
solutions backed by science answer a few
quick questions a doctor will review and
if they determine it's right for you can
prescribe
your medication to treat hair loss that
is shipped directly to your door get the
hair loss treatment everyone is talking
about featured in GQ Men's Health
Esquire and playboy to name a few
order now my listeners can get started
with hims complete hair kit for just
five dollars five bucks today right now
while supplies last
and subject to doctor approval see the
website for full details and safety
information this could cost hundreds if
you went to the doctor or a pharmacy
somewhere else go to four hems com / /
that's fo r hims com / Barbie you are R
for hims com / / and lastly is it lastly
in - more near LegalZoom come on in
zooms LegalZoom running your own
business isn't easy but getting help
with a lot of the day-to-day challenges
you face certainly helps that's why
business owners all around the country
turned to Legal Zoom over the commode
give it over the past 18 years Legal
Zoom has helped more than 2 million
business owners get started
but every entrepreneur knows getting
started is just the beginning of your
journey what happens along the way will
determine your success that's why legal
zooms network of independent attorneys
and tax professionals can help with oh
that's what they can help with ok
knowing where to turn for advice or
trademarks tax law changes in reviewing
contracts puts you at an advantage
you'll save money by avoiding hourly
fees since Legal Zoom isn't a law firm
don't get distracted by legal hurdles
and business questions as the Year winds
down go to legal Joe come today and find
out the different ways they can help
your business and don't forget to enter
the promo code bar in the box at
checkout
that's legalzoom.com promo code / Legal
Zoom where life meets
legal lastly but not leastly then please
stay oh [ __ ] simply safe everybody
according to the FBI the average loss in
a burglary is over two thousand bucks
but even so only one in five homes has
homes have home security most companies
really don't make it easy but simply
safe is different simply save for text
show your whole home every window room
and door didn't say [ __ ] about the
hallway with 24/7 monitoring 24/7
monitoring for just a fraction of the
cost their product they're like the
police discipline to read their policy
dispatch is up to three and a half times
policy their police dispatch if you know
how far away the computer is so I can
actually [ __ ] read it I'm really
realizing how much my eyesight is going
on me like I tried to kill a fly twice
this week with a fly swatter which is a
one-and-done operation
I missed both times I think I missed to
the right both time then I over
corrected all right whatever my the
police dispatch is up to three and a
half times faster than with other
companies because simply safe uses video
verification there's no contract hidden
fees or fine print this system is
designed to blend right into your home
no wires no drilling it's easy to order
and easy to set up usually in under an
hour
simply faith has won a ton of awards
from CNET to the New York Times wire
cutter prices are always fair and honest
around the clock monitor the clock
monitoring it's just $15 a month visit
simply safe bird comm you'll get free
shipping and a 60-day risk-free trial be
sure to go to simply safe bird comm so
they know our show sent you that simply
safe Burt calm oh my god I forgot to
[ __ ] do the announcement what a
[ __ ] idiot
I mean I'm a [ __ ] I'm gonna be doing
another live podcast I'm gonna be doing
this one in Los Angeles I'm gonna be
doing it on October 27th at 7 p.m. at
dynasty typewriter in Los Angeles on
sale
Monday morning no Jesus well nobody
knows about it because I've only
announced it here dynasty typewriter
com4 tickets presale code for podcast
listeners only is acetate let me double
check to see this is the right one that
I was supposed to read Monday morning
podcast live this is a special
announcement that I screwed up some pre
recording here on my phone or post
recording October 27th at 7 p.m. I'm
going to be a dynasty typewriter in Los
Angeles recording a live Monday morning
podcast the presale presale code for the
podcast listeners only is acetate AC e
ta te acetate it's on sale Monday at 4
p.m. Pacific Coast time dynasty
typewriter comm for tickets the code
will be required until noon on Wednesday
and then it's going to be on sale to the
public
alright that's it let's read some
[ __ ] [ __ ] from the listeners here
alright losing weight hey Bill
exclamation point I love your podcast
and you're special you make a lot of
jokes about fat guys and I have to say
I'm glad you do I'm overweight and I
used to be 327 pounds how tall are you
let's paint a picture and after hearing
you say these jokes instead of taking
offense to them I took it as a hey he
makes a point I got to do something
about my health yeah you do man why do
you want to [ __ ] he can't he can't blow
it out you can't blow it out you got a
you dick this is how you're gonna move
around the [ __ ] world it's like
you're beating the [ __ ] out of your self
alright I started to lose weight I cut
out soda do you know I've added soda to
my diet because I don't booze anymore
and I just you know sugar rush or
something I got it I got a knock it off
I stopped eating
out and started on home-cooked meals
that's huge I started doing cardio
within six months I'm now 278 look at
you let's do a quick math there that's
22 and 27 for t9 pounds you're crushing
it I want to thank you for really
opening my mind and setting a goal for
me to lose weight and gain muscle keep
up the great work well keep doing what
you're doing that's great
look at that say everybody thinks I'm a
negative [ __ ] I'm not I'm actually
positive you take time to get to know me
follow-up about med school good day fire
crotch now see that's offensive
I see that right there no normally I
could be offended by that but it's
inspiring me to dye my pubes all right
to the gentleman on your show who wanted
to go to medical school as it had been a
dream as it had been a dream of his
forever do it do it now if you really
wanted if you really wanted to do that
for years then just go get it I'm a
physician myself I received a degree in
history before going to medical school
then took my pre-med courses next thing
you know I was in med school I knew
almost nothing about medicine and the
like before going because pre-med is
biology and chemistry / physics biology
/ chemistry / physics but here I am now
and honestly they could teach a monkey
to do most of this stuff he just have to
be willing to put the work into into
learning the information like you should
have made this [ __ ] print bigger let
me bring the computer a little closer it
helps if you are single and nobody nags
you while you are in school in residency
which is like on-the-job training that
we all have to do chicks look at you
like you are some kind of badass which
is very unwarranted but I won't complain
and want your nuts all the time
especially and you can tell them the
chemical makeup of those [ __ ] balls
especially in residency when Docs and
nurses are young and horny if you are
willing to put the hours into the job
it's amazing
sounds like a [ __ ] you're helping
people and you're making a porno all at
the same time I can live anywhere in the
country at any time finding a job is
like finding sand on a beach all over
the place
good luck on your decision love the show
I love it because none of us me reading
in this listener have not been through
pre-med yet we're not smart enough that
you had to explain finding sand on the
beach by saying all over the place
and to you William sir lube up and shove
it in your anus Jesus all right
reply to 10/7 climate change comment
dear cube dear Billy q-ball burr you
know when you insult me you really
insult yourselves because once you're
saying about yourself all right we're
having a good day fire crunch they'll
see you like it there Billy q-ball bro
what our buddies comment is illogical
how about a little background any what
you talking about although I appreciate
their input if they thought about the
topic a little deeper I believe they
would come to a different conclusion
okay so so far you've just said the last
person is full of [ __ ] and if they
thought the way you did they come to
with the conclusion that you've done all
right issue number one
what about ism you may have heard this
term before no I haven't are you selling
me a Luke a used car hey Bill you're
smart but it's basically when someone
brings up a separate issue to remove
themselves from responsibility well I
think they also applied what about ISM
when they built the Space Shuttle hey
you know what if one of these things
comes loose
now-now-now that's what about ISM
example Sweden is critical about the
us's
pollution threshold USA responds with
but what about China okay I see what you
saying all right this has become an
extremely popular mechanism to avoid
answering questions or taking legitimate
action on most people's topics all this
the guy that was saying there basically
was no global warming or something I
can't remember anymore especially for
the current administration it's called
it's critical for us to be able to point
out when someone is using this mechanism
to [ __ ] their way out of something
okay I'll look for that issue number two
Industrial Development our buddy
mentioned that because China India and
other countries already late industrial
lysing stage that any action we take
towards Net Zero emissions would be
neutralized or useless this is painfully
simple simple alright this is what you
need to learn how to do you need to
learn to not talk down to people when
you make a point because you're talking
down to him and you're [ __ ] annoying
me I get it you're smart you have all
the [ __ ] answers here
this is painfully this is painful to
[ __ ] read this is this is I'll tell
you what this is a internet ism where
people don't have the ability to present
an opposite opinion without [ __ ] on
the other person alright that's what I
do all right
this is a painfully simple and linear
way to look at a situation it's not
mandatory for a country to follow a
specific pattern of industrial evolution
yeah but they usually follow what's
going to be the cheapest and I don't
think it's going to be going electric
and solar and all of that they're
probably going to use what is available
for them energy is energy if there is a
cheaper way to harness green energy
China in India would drop coal in a
heartbeat
this is rudimentary economics well
you're also but you're also avoiding
another thing I think that this is
painfully simple and linear okay because
of us you know you've got [ __ ] oil
companies that have been in power for
hundreds of years the money that they
have to influence that we continue going
down this [ __ ] road is off the charts
the way they can suppress information
the way they can buy companies that are
coming up with cleaner energy and just
own their patents and just put it on the
back burner
I mean I I mean I don't know I feel like
this is starting to feel like Santa
Claus here like though they're just
gonna winds vest and cleaner energies
and like I don't know I mean what why
aren't we over and [ __ ] the Middle
East right now what are we over there
for it to make sure Iraqi people are
free is that what we're doing they just
happen to be on top all that liquid gold
then this is rudimentary economics
it's about as it's about accessibility
to alternate forms of energy and
undercutting the oil industry easier
said than done but possible yeah I think
you're being painfully simple here
that's gonna create that's gonna cause
bloodshed dude those [ __ ] people
would put a bullet behind every baby's
[ __ ] ear cuz the way they have meant
that they could keep [ __ ] drilling
for oil the ends justifies the means
you're dealing with [ __ ] organized
sociopaths issue number three climate
conspiracy garbage for every bank funded
study there's thousands of independent
studies on the climate that all reached
the same conclusion even the US Navy
recognizes the climate change is its
largest existential threat an elementary
understanding of carbon particles would
tell you that human pollution is
directly causing the planet to heat
carbon particles survived in the
atmosphere for up to 10,000 years per
particle we're [ __ ] and retain
exponentially more heat than your usual
atmospheric particles but don't take my
word for it just read and critically
think that was so condescending or for
those of us that are on the simple side
I'm gonna turn your car on in the garage
with the door shut just chill out and
tell us what happens I mean do people
really think the particles just fly away
into outer space
these particles remain in the atmosphere
and oceans and have a very high heat
capacity that's [ __ ] that's terrif
I currently live in Miami so this issue
is very real for us even now soon the
water will be passed my nuts try to come
down here and do a show before it's all
under water
thanks - go [ __ ] yourself he actually
has a link here maybe he was just trying
to be funny he doesn't seem like that
bad a guy
maybe I'm just insecure about how stupid
I am and how I suck at reading out loud
alright there we go how about that
alright career advice I need some advice
on my career career advice for new
parent hey Billy ball dad big time fan
of your stand-up and podcast I
especially love the advice section oh do
you you like the advice section
[Music]
yells all right oh no not this thing is
gonna [ __ ] start playing something
elsea you like that you always get a
little taste of what the [ __ ] I'm
listening to little taste it I think I'm
actually a podcast listener somebody
sent me that I mean where the [ __ ] am I
here was that enough for you to Shazam
it all right conspiracy theory garbage
the delicate career
okay bald abba-baba-baba alright now
it's time for me to have give you some
advice I recently became a dad about six
months ago and I'm head over heels in
love with my new daughter my current job
is only 20 minute drive and seven 1/2
hours days the job is very easy and
laid-back and leaves me with a lot of
time to spend with my daughter the bad
part is the pay is terrible
yep you can have your cake and eat it
and I have to work a side job a couple
days a month just to stay out of the red
I resent that term I have recently been
offered a job that pays about 75% more
than what I'm making now this job
requires a lot of travel most days would
require 7 to 8 hours of work plus 3 to 4
hours of driving or an overnight stay at
a hotel oh Jesus all travel miles and
meals expenses are covered by the
company and benefits are solid I would
be home on weekends but during busy
weeks I might leave home on Monday
morning and not return until Friday
evening I would be missing a lot of time
with my daughter people say they grow up
very quickly and I want to be there as
much as possible I don't feel like I can
keep going with my current job though
one big one big car or home repair bill
and I'm in trouble I can't decide what
to do I could really use some advice
from a dad like you thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself your biggest fan of flora Jesus
dude this is a huge one I don't know
dude my gut tells me and this is I'm
going from my heart not my brain here is
to look for another keep looking for a
job you found that one you can
find the perfect job don't settle for
this one that'll be really [ __ ] hard
that would be really hard if you if that
would be happening a lot that you'd
leave Monday and not be home until
Friday I don't think you'll be on your
deathbed some day thinking hey thank God
I left on a Monday and came home on a
Friday and got all those great
experiences at that motel 6 but I will
think you'd be laying on your deathbed
thinking thank God I was able to see my
daughter Monday through Friday and hang
with her on the weekends there's other
things you can do you can downsize your
life you know there's just a lot of
extra [ __ ] now that people think
that they need and clutter and [ __ ]
you know you need a flat-screen in every
[ __ ] room in all of this [ __ ] you
really don't you don't need a lot of
[ __ ] that people think that you need and
me and my lovely wife I mean I was out
here in Los Angeles a car city we had
one car from oh seven to 2016 and we did
fine you know when I was growing up we
were a one-car family my mother put all
the kids in the car we drive to work
with my dad and then we'd all come home
together it's a lot of great times you
know depending if every was in a good
mood you know and then we feel that we'd
[ __ ] come home we had a great time so
I think now like there's there's a thing
about going on social media like you
just think you need to be living like
this MTV Cribs lifestyle and you can
really become a prisoner of that and you
know what the [ __ ] are you working for
you would I get free time is it's the
most valuable [ __ ] thing you could
ever have if you're making enough money
I know you know one bad thing happens
you're in the red is [ __ ] brutal that
I also understand that so I don't know
what that's like as a kid so take this
with a grain of salt but I do know what
it's like to put together a tricycle and
see your daughter riding around on it
and having the time to get on your bike
and ride with her it's amazing so
I don't know I would try and keep
looking for jobs I would talk to talk it
over with your wife in the end you have
to make that decision though there's too
many variables involved there
all right knee two lives dear Billy no
news I'm an exhausted college student I
spend the summer in South at other guy
just make like whatever your benefits
you're getting from that thing that's
what you want but without all of that
travel you know and go for exactly what
shoot for exactly what you want you fall
a little bit short who gives a [ __ ] but
I don't think you it doesn't sound like
you want to be doing that need to lives
dear Billy no news I'm an exhausted
college student I spent the summer in
South America on an internship and now
I'm back in the States catching up on my
favorite mind-numbing media I'm
listening to a podcast from a few months
ago will you talk about not paying
attention to epstein thing and just
having fun making the movie and hanging
in Central Park with your daughter
I myself was catching up on a lot of
stuff and realized that it all happened
without me paying attention also though
I've thought about running for local
government in my late 20s because I
actually give a [ __ ] I'm just not sure
which road I should take I enjoyed
taking caring about different things
while away and it's like goddamn I could
really use to separate lives so I don't
have to make this decision I really see
myself living both ways Oh either paying
attention or not PS I took a helicopter
ride in Chile and I really wish you were
piloting well I don't know anything
about anything down there so they all
about co-piloting I would say I I don't
know it'd be good to get a good person
in government but I feel like they weed
you out at the lower levels you gonna
play ball you're not gonna play ball and
I think that you could do it'd be great
to get somebody you know a good person
in government and then also there's a
lot of stuff that you can do outside of
government and I think the mistake that
I made was I thought politicians were
supposed to solve the problems and then
I just get to pay my taxes so I can sit
there and complain and drive by homeless
people and
all these other societal ills I think my
new thing is you know you want to get
something done do it yourself or at
least try and help somebody out that
knows how to organize it because I'm not
the best at that and you know like this
guy who just wrote in you know that's
the type of person that I you know if he
ever did the guy who wants to spend time
with his daughter you know if he did
have like a [ __ ] home repair or some
[ __ ] like that and it's just like he's
up against it I mean it's very easy you
know it's a I don't know come up with
something to help somebody out in that
situation everybody I don't know that's
just a more looking at like why don't we
help each other I like why would you let
your neighbor go through that why don't
we all have each other's backs cuz God
knows these [ __ ] people above us have
just they've just left they've just
they've left the program they just
sitting there competing with each other
and then going to islands and putting
animal heads on and [ __ ] each other
whatever l it is they're doing but they
have left us behind
and they've known for a long time what
we've been doing to the planet and
they've ignored it and they've chose
their yachts and their [ __ ] 20 year
old [ __ ] instead so I think if we have
any sort of shot everybody's got to try
and do something I don't know that's the
two cents from someone who doesn't read
here all right overrated / underrated
underrated having summer someone around
who gets into the holidays that's me I
already made some pumpkin bread trying
out this [ __ ] stove we just had it
[ __ ] rebuilt and I got to find out
how it how it bakes up ed to adjust
where I put the pumpkin bread in the
oven who I might make some tonight
underrated having someone around who
gets into the holidays I just moved back
home with my parents for a few months
between moving and law school I forgot
what it was like to have Halloween
decorations and baked delights around
otherwise what's it all for
oh it's [ __ ] tremendous and you got
to go you got to go hard on Halloween
you really do you got to decorate you
got to get into it so so the holidays
last as long as possible
alright overrated
dear Billy bone breath you know what
that means
overrated nice whether it gets old fast
every day becomes a new pressure to
somehow enjoy the beautiful day today
was raining in my part of the country
and I had no decision to make I would
work in the morning and then sit around
in my apartment till dinner
[ __ ] your picnics alright the guy knows
what he likes I like a nice rainy day
every once in a while it's tremendous
you know then you can [ __ ] there is
that great thing weather is there's no
pressure to God it's to this it's not
nice out or a great snowstorm that is
something I do miss out being here in LA
well it's just like some insane
snowstorm right you get the fire going
your wife gets some food you start
cooking right the lights go out you
pretend like you know what you're doing
as a man you know all of that [ __ ] I do
enjoy a law that all right well my
kiddos up from her nap I'm gonna go
[ __ ] ride a bicycle while she rides a
tricycle and enjoy myself alright
everybody
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on you
on Thursday and yeah that's it we'll
talk more see